hello everyone and welcome to the second
round of the us chess championship we
skipped round one as it wasn't very
eventful uh so we're starting off uh
with round two and we have a very nice
game between wesley so and the darius
schwerz uh now as it says on their
website the 2021 u.s championship is a
12 player round robin featuring the
strongest strongest players in the
united states uh and they compete for
194 000
and um
of course the title of the us champion
uh if more players type for first place
there will be a playoff uh and the uh
games last 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then you get additional 30
moves for the rest of the game 30
seconds increment
is being gained by every movie play so
when you hit the clock and that's pretty
much it you are not allowed to offer a
draw before move 30. so uh that being
said let's check it out and then we're
gonna discuss the tournament a little
bit and of course uh the standings well
not standings okay we're gonna show the
standings after round three let's say
but it's a very nice game uh it's a very
short game and uh it really shows how um
a double edged it can be to to try and
surprise
a top tier player in chess so without
further ado let's check it out wesley
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have c5 by schweitz going for the
sicilian defense knight f3 d6 and now
bishop to b5 check wesley goes for the
canal attack we have bishop to d7
wesley trades we have bishop captures
queen captures and now c4 so grabbing
more control in the center the d5 square
is now definitely in white's control
however you relinquish the control of
the d4 square so if you're not careful
black might put a knight there so this
could be very annoying so knight to f6
knight to c3 and both players develop
all of their knights we have d4 striking
in the center uh and now usually black
just captures on d4 but here shirts goes
for a very very rare continuation and
that is queen to g4 and here uh white
has really a lot to consider c captures
on d4 seems like a good option knight
captures an e4 seems like a good option
queen captures and g2 seems like a good
option and more often than not white
just castles here because uh if you go
for the e4 pawn that's not going to end
well for you for example if knight
captures on e4 we're going to play
knight characters queen captures and
then d5 and you have problems here now
queen to a4 check is coming and this
will be very unpleasant you you okay you
don't have to move the king you could
play some like 95 queen a4 check 97 but
rookie one and that black king will be
there for a very long time and you kind
of don't want to castle queen side white
could very easily just destroy that this
uh and start an attack against the black
king so uh in the hands of someone like
wesley so this position is very much
winning for white
uh so instead after this uh g queen to
g4 move uh wesley doesn't castle uh this
line that we've shown is not forced of
course i i just wanted to show you why
knight captures an e4 can be played but
he goes for d5 and now what do you play
here okay knights to d4 now we did put a
knight here as we said knight captures
on d4 we have a queen trade queen
captures on d1 wesley recaptures with
the knight you don't have to worry about
this pawn because black has to waste the
tempo uh
recapturing the piece so knight captures
on d1c captures on d4 and now f3 nicely
strengthening the center here the e4
pawn is now nicely defended and there
are a few games where e5 was played but
here actually goes for rook the c8
attacking the c4 pawn and it is now only
as a movie 11 that we have a completely
new game uh so let's see how wesley
continues he defends the pawn b3 and now
he has a beautiful pawn chain here but
like all things that are beautiful it
can easily be destroyed and at some
point we might expect something like a6
b5 or the knight moves and then we're
going to play f5 so the pawn chain will
be challenged at some point so first we
have e5 now uh black already has a pass
pawn so this could be very dangerous and
it doesn't really do anything if you
capture alpaca uh black would will just
recapture and then play e5 um so the the
d4 pawn will be nicely defended but
wesley just continues with the g4 he
says i control a lot of space i want to
control more space so g5 is coming then
we're going to play maybe h4 and black
will have to figure out how to develop
his pieces because the bishop here
is not really a great bishop you know as
they say if you have all of your pawns
on dark squares well not all of them but
most of them you do not want to have a
dark square bishop you want to have a
light square bishop or if you have a
dark square bishop you want to put your
pawns on light squares so here we have
bishop to e7 and now king to e2 wesley
doesn't need the castle the queens are
off the board there really isn't any
danger so it makes sense to have an
active central king uh and now schweitz
goes for h5 he would very much enjoy
opening up the h5 for his rook but
wesley says i was going to push g5
anyway so let's just do it g5 pushes
back the knight knight to d7 and now
bishop to d2 uh you don't have to play
h4 right away the bishop is defending
the pawn here so
you might as well wait with with the
push of the pawn because pawns are
the only pieces that can't really go
back so once you push them they're just
there so here we have castles by
schweitz uh now preparing maybe a move
like f6 or f5 trying to open up the df
file for the rook and knight to f2
wesley wants to bring the knight to d3
there he will have support for f4 but
also he will have very nice support for
c5 if he ever needs it in the future so
here we have a6 black is preparing b5
and now knight to d3 so for the moment
you can't really
uh go for b5 right away it seems like
something you really want to do because
we discussed how you want to challenge
this beautiful pawn chain that wesley
has the problem is after captures and
captures white just plays a4 and the
white is the one who will uh create a
pass pawn the material on the board is
completely equal but with black having
doubled the d pawns it's uh white who's
kind of up a pawn it's a two to one
advantage on the queen side and this is
very important in positions like this so
after knight to d3 we have f5 of course
black wants to
challenge white center and open up the f
file for the rook but now wesley can
just capture with the g pawn so g
captures an f6 alpha song g captures on
f6 well black also improves his position
in the center and rook h the g1 check
you could also bring this rook to g1 but
this pawn this rook really doesn't have
all that much to do here so rook the g1
check king to h7 and now rook to g3 now
wesley is ready to double up on the g
file
and here you really don't have all that
many options your bishop isn't doing all
that much the knight really
also doesn't have all that many squares
if you play knight c5 and trade off the
knights then
you've traded off your only active piece
you're gonna you're gonna be left with a
bishop who's uh stuck behind the the
pawns that are on dark squares so here
you should play some like rook to g8 and
after let's say rook eight to g1 we
could see a trait captures capture so
white would improve his spawn chain
f4 would be coming uh but
you know black uh black is playing this
but in the game schweitz tried h4 and
this simply will not to do uh for a very
specific reason so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
move here for wesley while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook to
g4
that's the good stuff yes uh and this uh
isn't with the idea of winning a pawn
because black of course will play f5
that's the idea and the pawn will be
defended but we want to make black waste
a move play f5 and this will give us
just enough time to double up rooks on
the g file and then our rook can come to
g7 hopefully and look at this bishop and
knight on this seventh rank that's just
easy food for the rook uh we often say
uh like uh the good old josh waitskin
taught us that the rook on the seventh
rank is called a pig so here we have f5
black of course has to defend the h4
pawn e captures on f5 rook captures and
now rook 8 the g1 going for that rook to
g7 check so of course you have to defend
uh if you play rook f7 this defends this
but then bishop the b4 comes puts
pressure on the pawn then rook to g6
comes and the white will have a very
clear idea of how to
continue playing this so instead we have
rook to e8 now the bishop is nicely
defended but now knight to f2 now the
knight is coming here and then the
knight will put pressure on the d6 pawn
and on black's position in general so
knight to f6 attacking wesley's rook and
only now rook the g7 check king h8 and
now another brilliant move rook to f7
beautiful rook the g7 is now coming
we're gonna double up on the seventh
rank uh the knight cannot move as the
rook would hang uh so it's a really
really difficult position for black to
handle we have rooked the h5 now the
knight can move but now rook to g6 every
move wesley plays here is just uh
spectacular now the the the threat is
very simple we're going to capture the
bishop after rook captures we're going
to pick up the knight so we're going to
win uh two pieces for a rook so knight
the g8 and now comes knight to e4 so
just mounting the pressure now the d6
pawn is hanging so we have to do
something about this rook to d8
defending the pawn and now uh bishop to
g5 you could also just play rook
captures on g8 this is perfectly fine
we'll remove the defender of the bishop
and then we pick it up
but wesley says there's no need to rush
this we can just play bishop to g5 first
put more pressure on white and it
doesn't matter what white plays if
bishop captures knight captures there's
really no play left here for black we're
just going to play rook g7 rook h7 and
deliver checkmate or if the knight moves
we can just capture the knight so
nothing really works for here for black
so after uh bishop to g5 we have rook to
h7 trying to relieve some pressure try
and get some rooks off the board
but here wesley says all right now we
don't really care rook captures on e7
and now what do you play if knight
captures on e7 then you simply play
bishop to f6 check
the only move for black is the block
with the rook now we pick this up with
the rook for example and now all sorts
of nasty discoveries are being
threatened we're already up a piece but
we're going to win a lot more so after
rook captures on e7 schwerz plays rook
captures on e7 but now wesley plays the
absolute uh
best move in the position and that is
bishop captures an h4 there are other
great moves here of course you could
play anything and still win but this is
just nicely collecting a pawn and saying
to black you you have no moves here
whatsoever so both of the rooks are
hanging uh there's nothing to play here
if you play something like rook here
trying to give up some material we're
just gonna capture it and then capture
the d6 pawn we're now up two pawns of
course the position is completely
winning and schwierz knows that this
would be completely hopeless to try and
play this against wesley you don't have
a way of activating your knight the rook
has really nothing to do here and white
already has a pass deep on so
it would be hard even without being up
two pawns but being up two points it's
impossible
so after bishop captures an h4 schweizer
resigned and a very nice victory for
wesley so who is currently tied for
first place after two rounds have been
played so only 32 moves and here you can
see just how dangerous it is to
try something like this so it's a it was
definitely a prepared line like we said
rook the c8 was a new move so schwerz
prepared very well
and then everything up until the point
uh where he played h4 was still maybe
tenable but after h4 wesley just played
the absolute best uh possibility uh on
every move and that was uh more than
enough
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
wesley so showing us uh how to uh punish
even the slightest of uh inaccuracies uh
i would like to thank anima mosseni idol
gumruk minkha kennedy now tom darrell
and robert kiefer for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions continuing the the coverage
of the us chess championship and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day